[Musique]
au soir les petits enfants vous savez
aujourd'hui nous allons vous raconter
notre long voyage grosos vous a fait de
très beaux dessins
il n'a pas arrêté de travailler de toute
la journée je descends les montrer mes
deux petits amis et moi je vous
raconterai le voyage un tout à l'heure à
toute à leur patron hum hum up ne
regroupe pas
[Musique]
et bien c'est un très curieux voyage que
celui que nous avons fait en vous
quittant il y à un mois
nous avons rencontré dans le ciel un
étrange monsieur qui s'appelle monsieur
carnaval
les images c'est ça monsieur carnaval
oui c'est monsieur carnaval dans son
avion de fleurs mais oui monsieur
carnaval avec un avion tout en fleurs il
avait décidé de faire le tour de la
terre et chaque fois qu'ils arrivaient
dans une ville il y avait une fête mais
alors une fête extraordinaire pas
seulement une fête où l'on mange des
gâteaux mais une fête où tout le monde
se déguise où tout le monde danse où
tout le monde chante et où l'on jette en
l'air des confettis des pétards des
bonbons et des fleurs
j'ai dit à manger beaucoup de bonbons
cause oui beaucoup trop dans la première
fête
les gens portaient des masques
extraordinaire peints de toutes les
couleurs et il marchait sur des échasses
pour est très grand il dansait dans la
rue comme de cigognes qui portent des
basques dans un autre pays
monsieur carnaval avait lui aussi mis un
masque
il voulait ressembler aux habitants de
ce pays
c'était un très joli masque de chinois
car nous étions en chine
et là nous avons vu de très grosses
bêtes en papier qu'on appelle des
dragons grosos avait un peu peur j'ai eu
lieu le carnaval où il y avait des
fleurs
oh oui le carnaval de nice où il n'y
avait que des fleurs étaient vraiment
très beau
et quand monsieur carnaval est arrivé
dans son bel avion la fête a battu son
plein la fanfare s'est mise à jouer deux
fois plus fort alors nous avons compris
que monsieur carnaval avait retrouvé son
vrai pays et ses vrais amis
il nous sommes revenus sur notre petit
nuage vous voir ainsi que nous avions
promis c'est des fleurs du carnaval oui
c'est des fleuves de carnaval allons au
dôme noms cités pour tous ces carnavals
surtout celui avec les flériens aussi
celui avec les dragons
oui je dormais vite à tous demain minuit
louis bony modèle
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les petits enfants à demain allez vite
vous coucher embrassez vos parents et en
dormez vous bien sagement au revoir
petit louis au revoir mirabel bonne nuit
à demain
bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh
en haut
[Musique]